I'm super-competitive buddy is super
competitive and Heather is really
competitive too
the only person who's not that
competitive is Lenny sloths
or elephants oh my god you could ever
choose that's what I was thinking
I felt yeah that was easy how
embarrassing is it gonna be if Heather
and Buddy beat us they have been
together for not even half the time that
Lenny and I have alright ready one two
three oh yeah and you wanted to just
Lofton you changed it didn't you oh yeah
well I started doing elephants and then
I did sloth and I change out there once
we get a question right I'm feeling
really optimistic like we're on track
and we're about to slay this does he
want a prenup or no prenup
oh oh yeah alright that's great for you
guys if he could visit any country in
the world where would it be
yeah what is her favorite food hey are
you kidding
have we even been together for the last
year am i sleeping with a stranger like
is this real life everyone knows that my
favorite food is pasta don't forget to
give us our point oh I got a baby thank
you
hmm what are her favorite pizza toppings
sweetheart if you don't know this what
did I get most of them are either like
one of them wrong it's the same pizza I
order every time um I'm just gonna go
one answer that no sweetheart what do
you mean it's toppings you know we go
there instead what
because you said he said I'm just gonna
go with one you said no toppings no you
said no to him no topping you're
influencing his answer way more than
saying yo with your hey you said no to
him when he was gonna put just one are
you ready yeah 1 2 3
let's go uh-oh there you go you mean me
all right
at this point I'm not only annoyed that
we're losing but it is being made
obvious that we don't know each other as
well as I thought we did this is not a
good sign for Lenny and me we just got
it so boom yeah good job you guys win is
the ultimate couple take it gasps ooh
far I mean ultimately the game was about
how well you know your significant other
ask me though I don't know maybe they
just need that you know both kiss